*Clappement de mains*
*Bruit strident fort*
Yo, c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce Coup de Phil'.
On a tous une petite phobie, ça peut aller de l'arachnophobie à l'idéophobie, la peur des idées...
- Mieux vaut pas qu'il sorte de la caverne celui-là !
... en passant par la bitrochosophobie... La peur des bicyclettes.
Mais comment peut naître une phobie ?
Une des personnes qui nous a aidés à avoir des éléments de réponse à cette question,
c'est un scientifique qui a fait une expérience :
c'est l'expérience des chiens de Pavlov.
*Clappement de mains*
*Bruit strident fort*
Pavlov, c'est un scientifique Russe, qui va faire une expérience en 1889
sur le conditionnement classique, c'est un concept du Behaviorisme.
Le Behaviorisme c'est la science des comportements, c'est un courant de pensée en psychologie.
L'expérience est plutôt simple :
En gros, il y a des événements qui vont entraîner des réactions chez les organismes vivants.
Ces événements, on les appelle : Stimulus.
Et il y a plusieurs types de stimulus :
Déjà, le stimulus neutre, il n'entraîne aucune réaction prédéfinie.
Par exemple si je fais sonner une cloche,
il ne va rien se passer sur ton organisme.
- Non, c'est pas vrai, des fois je t'en...
- Attends, attends, je crois que je t'ai pas sonnée.
Il y a aussi le stimulus inconditionnel qui entraîne une réponse inconditionnelle.
C'est une réponse que tu n'as pas appris, qui est de l'ordre du réflexe.
Par exemple, si je te souffle dans les yeux, tu vas les fermer automatiquement.
Okay, maintenant qu'on a les bases, passons à l'expérience.
*Clappement de mains*
*Bruit strident fort*
On prend un chien, donc ça, c'est Sky, le chien de ma sœur... Dédicace
Qui ne ressemble pas du tout aux chiens de Pavlov d'ailleurs.
Quand le chien perçoit de la nourriture,
il sécrète beaucoup de salive, la glande salivaire fonctionne à fond.
Donc la perception de nourriture, c'est un stimulus inconditionnel
avec pour réponse inconditionnelle la sécrétion de salive.
Sauf que Pavlov va rajouter juste avant un son de cloche, à chaque fois qu'il donne de la bouffe.
C'est un stimulus neutre.
Le stimulus neutre, doit se trouver avant le stimulus inconditionnel, attention.
Et il fait l'expérience plein de fois.
Si bien qu'au bout d'un moment, le son de cloche à lui tout seul,
sans la bouffe, déclenche la sécrétion de salive.
C'est donc devenu un stimulus conditionnel et la sécrétion de salive est dans ce cas une réponse conditionnelle.
Pavlov à donc à ce moment là réussi à conditionner un chien !
Et il aurait pu le faire avec de l'air, ça aurait donné de l'air conditionné !
*Bruits de rires* Merci
Je précise qu'en vrai, c'est un peu moins glamour que ça, hein...
C'est à dire qu'en fait, il tranche la joue du chien, tu vois,
il ouvre bien, il met un tuyau, il visse le tuyau pour récupérer la salive du chien,
et au lieu de donner de la bouffe, il balance de la viande en poudre.
Donc...hum... Vive le respect de l'animal...
Je vous laisse imaginer comment il promène son chien...
*Musique douce*
*Clappement de mains*
*Bruit strident fort*
Et le conditionnement marche aussi avec les Hommes,
comme le montre l'expérience du petit Albert.
Alors en gros, il a un professeur qui s'appelle le professeur Watson,
qui va donner une souris blanche à un gosse de trois ans qui va jouer avec.
Sauf que le gosse déteste le bruit de deux règles qui s'entrechoquent.
Il déteste ça.
Et bien en fait, à chaque fois que le gosse va voir la souris, Watson *BIM*, lui envoie un gros son dégueulasse dans la tête,
et du coup le gosse va développer une phobie des souris blanches,
et même une phobie de tout ce qui a un pelage blanc et même une phobie des masques de père Noël.
On appelle ça la généralisation :
en fait, tu vas étendre le stimulus conditionnel.
"Albert ! On t'a acheté un nouvel ordinateur !
- Ah ! Merci, c'est trop...
- Albert, ça n'a pas l'air d'aller ....
(musique angoissante)
Le conditionnement peut être plus ou moins fort
et on peut même le perdre avec par exemple la désensibilisation systématique.
En gros c'est une technique qui va consister à travailler sur ta réponse conditionnelle,
pour la changer petit à petit face au stimulus conditionnel de plus en plus fort,
de sorte à ne plus avoir de problème face à ce stimulus.
*Clappement de mains*
*Bruit strident fort*
Au final, le conditionnement classique on y fait face inconsciemment tous les jours
C'est par exemple quand tu vas entendre la musique de ton réveil en plein milieu de la journée,
et que ça va te donner un petit coup de stress et d'anxiété.
*Bruit électronique de réveil*
C'est ce qui peut arriver devant les pubs aussi :
on peut associer le nom d'un produit avec une sensation de bien être.
Dans le cadre de cette pub, on est finalement pas très loin de l'expérience des chien de Pavlov...
C'est aussi pour ça que le conditionnement classique peut être vivement critiqué.
C'est par exemple le cas dans "Orange mécanique", de Stanley Kubrick,
où on réhabilite Alex grâce à un conditionnement hardcore.
*Cris*
*Clappement de mains*
Bah alors?
Ne me dites pas que je vous ai conditionnés en quelques minutes ?
Et bien a priori, non.
Déjà parce que quatre minutes c'est très short,
et en plus vous avez dû peut-être comprendre mon petit manège,
prendre conscience de ce que j'essayais de faire,
et quand on en prend conscience, c'est une autre paire de manches.
C'est plus de la psycho que de la philo certes,
mais ça touche à l'analyse et à la compréhension des mécanismes de l'Homme,
et c'est un truc que j'adore.
Tout ce que j'adore, j'ai envie de vous le partager.
Remarquez d'ailleurs que ce que l'on vient de voir peut s'opposer à la vidéo #4 sur l'Existentialisme,
puisque si par rapport à certaines choses on est conditionné, et qu'on suit finalement une loi
d'action... réaction,
eh bien quelque part, on remet un petit peu en jeu notre liberté.
Je vous laisse réfléchir là dessus et je vous envoie du love et de la peace...
YOLO !